[Musique]
s
trèsus l'objectif c'est vraiment de les
éveiller à quelque chose de beau et la
passion pour un métier que l'on fait non
pas parce qu'il a bien fallu faire
quelque chose et que par défaut on va se
diriger vers ça parce que papa et maman
nous ont dit que c'était bien d'être
notaire ou
avocat mais pour l'instant vous faites
rien elle est encore un peu chaude
déposezles dans 3 minutes j'ai
l'impression que ces métiers là a l'air
plus amusant que d'autres métiers qui
rapporte peut-être plus d'argent mais je
préfère être passionné et je pense que
oui je vais faire un métier avec de l'or
dans les
mains
si pas de spatule
[Musique]
c'est une vraie richesse en France les
métiers d'art on devrait plus prendre le
temps de leur faire découvrir ces
métiers
[Musique]
là
c'est super parce que justement il y a
plein de personnes qui savent pas
vraiment où s'orienter et du coup bah je
trouve c'est bien parce que comme ça il
peuent un peuah voir qu'est-ce qui peut
leur
[Musique]
intéresser aujourd'hui on a également de
gros problème de recrutement dans les
métiers manuels la CMA parle de 300000
entreprises artisanales à reprendre
d'ici 10 ans la majorité des chefs
d'entreprise ont plus de 55 ans et on n
pas cette nouvelle génération qui va
reprendre le flambau parce qu'on n pas
du tout parlé de ces métiers aux jeunes
aujourd'hui chez de leur dans les mains
65 % de nos bénéficiaires ne
connaissaient pas ces métiers avant de
débuter le programme donc ça veut dire
que ça fait plus du tout partie de leur
imaginaire collectif et nous on veut
évidemment leur donner envie d'aller
vers ses
métiers
[Musique]
c'est incroyable de le faire je le fais
pour pour ma mère bah c'est c'est
passionnant d'apprendre de d'apprendre
de nouvelles choses et d'apprendre aussi
à faire des
fleurs et j'ai vraiment adoré cette
journée on a quand même deux élèves sur
trois qui disent avoir été fi de faire
quelque chose avec leurs mains lors de
l'atelier on a également des jeunes qui
se disent qu'il n'excluent plus de faire
un métier avec leurs mains donc on se
dit qu'on a peut-être SEM met une petite
[Musique]
graine y